hello everybody and welcome to another
python 3 tutorial
uh in the last tutorial we were talking
about
strings in the print function and in
this tutorial what we're going to be
talking about is just basic mathematics
within python
so
uh with that i'll just show you guys
you've got obviously your typical
operators you've got the plus sign minus
sign you've got multiplication and you
have division
so with that i'm just going to comment
this out for now
i guess i never really mentioned
commenting out either so now would be a
good time to just mention
uh if you use the pound sign that
results in a single line comment
um and so basically all a comment is is
just something that doesn't
it's not really
when python goes over it it recognizes
it as a comment and it doesn't do
anything with it so you could say print
hi right and if we run this
it prints high it doesn't do anything
here
and so by that same token if you did
like print
hi
you would think it you know maybe it'll
print twice but no it just prints that
single high so that's a single line
comment there's also multiple line
comments so the way to do that is
uh with three single quotes here uh you
can also do a double quotes and then you
can put whatever you want within here
uh and that's a multiple line comment so
if you just you're you know you're
long-winded in all your discussions uh
like me then you use a lot of these
anyway so uh that's just comments since
i used it here uh so anyways now back to
mathematics so the operations that you
can do obviously uh the first one we see
is addition so we could do one plus
three you don't actually have to print
anything so when you actually call
uh one plus three
or at least in the old one it used to it
would return it but let's do it here i
guess let's see if it'll do it so it's
returning it here but for whatever
reason i won't return it
huh
that's interesting
i guess we'll print it out then no i'm
not quite sure why i won't i guess we
can do it in here anyways so we'll just
do it live in here normally you know you
wouldn't just randomly put a one plus
three like that's not doing anything
anyways you would assign it to a
variable or whatever
uh but anyways you can do mathematics
here so one plus three equals four you
can also do
uh three minus one
you can do multiplication so four times
four
uh you can also do division and division
is uh something special within python
3.3 or actually three anything three and
above
because in two seven if you did five
divided by two or i guess if you did
five divided by two you'd probably get
one
and if you did five divided by like four
you'd get zero i think
because i wanted to work in whole
numbers only but with uh
three and above and you it works the way
you would expect it to work uh and it
you do indeed get two point five and if
you do oops well if that works too i
suppose
um and you can get like a float out of
it and all that so
that's that obviously in python 2 you
would have to either call one of these
afloat
to get that or
you could you know from future import
division
which future is python 3 but anyways so
that's that you've got division a couple
other things that you can do um well
really only really one more thing i'd
like to show you is four
multiplied by four now what that's going
to are multiplied multiplied what that's
going to do is actually do four to the
square to the
i can't think right now it's getting it
it's the like makes it an exponent right
so you've got 4 to the power of that's
what i was looking for
4 to the power of 4 and then when you do
that you get 256.
so that's that um
there are a couple other things that you
can do that i'll show you guys later on
like like we did um or we will do is
like a counter
so you could do like four plus equals
one
uh that's actually not even going to let
us do it here so anyway i guess you'll
see that later so now uh that's pretty
much
all i want to cover with the math i
wonder if four plus equals one works in
two seven i did notice that this is kind
of it acts differently because it does
act differently
uh because there are actually different
types of data as you type it in here and
maybe that's why it's doing this but
anyway i thought i would be able to get
away with that but no so anyways uh
that's gonna conclude just the basic
mathematics within python tutorial we
never actually ended up using this
uh that's okay
so if you guys have any questions feel
free to post them below
uh otherwise stay tuned in the next
video as always thanks for watching
thanks for all your support and your
subscriptions
until next time